LUKE SCHENN...
TIPS THE PUCK IN TO THE
PITTSBURGH ZONE.
GAME STILL AWAITING ITS FIRSTST
PENGUINS NEARLY 6 MINUTES IN TO.
BOESER TAKES THE PUCK AWAY.
NOW AT THE BLUE LINE, TYLERNG G
MILE AN HOUR SHOT! -- PARDON MEY
TO SEE PLAYERS WHO
HAVE HAD BREAKS DUE TO COVID SC.
HE'S NOT THE
KRIS LETANG ALL THE WAY ACROSS
FOR RODRIGUES, COMES
SHOTS.
THERE'S A GOOD CHANGE
HERE AS KYLE BURROUGHS PLAYS THE
PUCK GENTLY TO THE PITTSBURGH
F
DEFLECTED, IT'S IN!
[ Crowd cheering ]N GET A SHOT .
NOW IT'S BACK AGAIN.
TIPPED
WIDE BY CARTER.
CANUCKS TRYING TO BREAK OUT
CROSBY LETS IT GO.
BLOCKED.
THAT BROKE THE STICK OF TYLER
MYERS.
REBOUND, RODRIGUES, STOPPED BY
DEMKO!
LOOSE PUCK!
MOTTE CLEARED ITT
CANUCKS, THOUGH, DIDN'T BREAK.
AND GAVE IT TO THE PENGUINS.HE
IN.
McGINN BEHIND THE GOALohn S.: M
FIVE-ON-THREE.
THAT ONE HIT OLIVER
EKMAN-LARSSON AG
I KNOW IT'S A FIFIGAME.
USUALLY YOU LOOK AT BETWEEN 30
ANONIGHT WITH THE
CANUCKS TRAILING BY TWO.P IS KY
BUT OFF SIDE WAS ALEX CHIASSON
SO THE WHISTLE STOPS
WE SAW ALL THE WILD FINISHES IN
THE EARLIER GAMES. ABLE TO KICK
BACK.
GOES TO TIPS THE
PUCK TO THE CORNER.